إنها فكرة كلب عن نزهة ممتعة ، كل تلك
الروائح تنبعث من خياشيمه ، لكن
بالنسبة إلى صوفي ، كانت كل تلك الروائح في
الهواء الطلق مغرية للغاية ، كان الجرو البالغ من العمر ستة أشهر
يركب مع عائلتها الحاضنة على
الطريق السريع 101 في لوس أنجلوس عندما قال رايان كريمر
إنه  وكان أطفاله يشمّون رائحة
نزلناها عبر النوافذ ، لقد كان
يخرج رأسها من النافذة يشم رائحة
مثل أي كلب آخر تالٍ تعرفه ،
تمامًا مثل إطلاق النار من
السيارة التي التقطتها كاميرا تسلا ،
تحولت صوفي تقريبًا إلى قتل طريق بالكاد
تتجنب  شاحنة تعبر حقل ألغام من
السيارات توقف سائق سيارة آخر خلف ريان
أيضًا ووضع مصابيحه الوامضة
نوعًا ما من حركة المرور البطيئة ، ثم كان
يساعد صوفي في الوقت الذي وصلت فيه إلى
هناك ، أخذ كرامرز مزيج الجحر
إلى الطبيب البيطري كانت مصابة بكسر في الفخذ
وخدوش ولكن الآن في طريق
التعافي ، لم تكن صوفي أول كلب
يخرج من سيارة أوقف جندي ولاية أوريغون هذا سائقًا
مسرعًا وكان
يداعب الصلصال أحصل عليه ، يحدث
كل شيء نحن بشر عندما أطلق كلب ثان
نافذة ،
قام الضابط بإلقاء القبض على ما وصفته الشرطة
بالمتآمر المشارك ، وترك الكلب
والسائق يخرجان بوقت تحذير فقط ،
حذرت الملصقات ريان كرامر من أنه
لا يجب أن تفتح هذه النافذة على مصراعيها أبدًا
مع الجرو في السيارة.
ستعمل المكالمة على زيادة الوعي
ويبدو أن كرامرز
سيرفعون صوفي بشكل دائم الآن لقد كنت
أتوسل من أجل جرو مثل هذا كان حلمي ،
لذا فإن
البقاء على قيد الحياة قد يجعلها كلبًا معجزة لكنها
ليست مستضعفة ، فهذه طريقة أفضل
من إلصاقك  الخروج من مزاج
غسيل السيارات
سي إن إن نيويورك